[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu vettel nach dem tod der
schlagzeilen macht der nächsten 15
minuten werden sie ein feuerwerk der
meinungen erleben vom klima protesten
über die inflation hin zur katholischen
kirche diese vielfalt schafft keine
andere show meine gäste am patricia
riekel 20 jahre lang war sie die
chefredakteurin von burdas bunte sie ist
die grand dame des boulevard und weiß
genau warum das leben von prominenten
politikern unsere gesellschaft so reizt
neben ihr finanzexperte und sechsfacher
spiegel bestseller autor max übrig sein
buch die größte chance aller zeiten ist
er erfolgreichster wirtschaftsbuch
2021 an meiner seite bild chefredakteur
und tv chef claus strunz er moderierte
das kanzlerduell und trifft mit seinen
pointierten meinungen den nerv vieler
millionen deutsche last but not least
unser stammgast journalist kolumnist
hans ulrich jörges und jetzt hören sie
genau zu 960 zwischenrufe erschien von
ihm im stern die financial times tätig
sind ein flussreisen kommentatoren der
welt und olivia wyss wird
glücklicherweise nicht müde den
mächtigen auf die finger was ist heute
daran lassen
und ich habe mich heute mal über gar
nichts aufgeregt deswegen ich meine
arbeit heute dem lkw-fahrer widmen
möchte den mein kollege peter wilke beim
klima protest traf
wollen sie uns was dazu sagen
was halten sie davon dass die reconf
einheiten ganz ehrlich diese absolute
scheiße sie sollen bei den politikern
hochgehen und nicht hier uns und wir
haben alle zu tun sie machen ihren job
ich mache meinen job und dann machen die
stören dabei es reicht wir können
zufrieden sein dass ich jetzt ein
schöner effekt habe dass ich entspannt
bin ich schon da vorne ja
guter mann
der ein wahres wort gelassen aus spricht
also ich weiß ich genau was er meint ich
gebe ihm total recht weil ich habe mich
auch darüber aufgeregt war habe ich mich
über einen bestimmten aspekt dieser
geschichte aufgeregt nach meiner
wahrnehmung ich habe das in der
abendschau des rbb es erste mal gesehen
dass da so eine kleine kette von vier
fünf leuten quer von abfahrt von der
autobahn saß und ganzen verkehr
aufgehalten hat die berichterstattung
über diese paar hanseln hat dafür
gesorgt dass die nicht mehr aufgehört
haben und es wurde immer wieder nach
berichtet noch mal neu noch mal neu noch
mal wurden immer bedeutender diesen
völlig unbedeutend aber die haben jetzt
die mediale bedeutung gewonnen sie haben
ja schon mal was geschafft haben wir
schon mal gewundert also bei herr scholz
haben diese klima protest schon mal
gehungert damit werden sie auf ihrer
webseite der schweiz getroffen habe und
ich glaube sie haben ganze merkt so
funktioniert da hat sich herr scholz
auch nicht drüber geärgert sondern hat
gar nicht hingeguckt aber die lkw
fahrern die autofahrer die irgendwas
vorhaben es gibt ja nicht mehr so viele
leute in berlin die neue arbeit
nachgehen das hat mich mal weniger aber
ein paar gibt es schon auch die kommen
damit der autobahn reingefahren aus
brandenburg haben etwas zu erledigen und
stehen da und gucken auf fünf sechs
leute die quer über die straße sitzen
und das ist aus meiner sicht ein ganz
schädlicher ausschließlich an medien
effekt die sind es nicht wert über sie
zu berichten wenn wir eine ordentliche
klima eine große klima demonstration in
berlin haben wo 10.000 leute umgehen es
eine völlig andere geschichte das
verstehe ich total aber die nicht es
tritt auf jeden fall die falschen würde
ich auch sagen wir sitzen da ich fast
sagen wohlstands verwahrlost es ist ein
zeichen von spätrömischer dekadenz und
möchten irgendwie wegen essen usw darauf
hinweisen was hier schief läuft dann
sollen sie für supermärkte gehen oder
vernetzten welt erklären wir noch mal
ganz kurz dagegen
dagegen habe die demonstrieren dafür
dass essen nicht vergeudet wird aber
wenn die krankenpflegerin geht es
irgendwie zu ihrem 80-jährigen patientin
muss oder die mutter die ihr kind vom
kindergarten abholen will dagegen tun
oder was kann die denn dafür und da
trifft es definitiv die falsche und es
wird auch den unmut weiter befeuern dass
leute sagen was sind das für spinner
kennt man die überhaupt die spinne nein
es sind ja nicht mal wenn es nur sieben
oder acht leute sind also in münchen
würde die polizei kommen würde sie dann
hoch wenn sie an sich
festgestellt sicherlich fällt
festgeklebt war nicht so leicht
sind wirklich ja gewisse das ist ja auch
entschuldigen ich glaube nur dass das
man aussehen muss machen wir einmal für
eine sekunde dreht wie immer wohlwollend
gegenüber sollen auf etwas aufmerksam
macht ja eben immer noch die worte
meiner 16 jährigen tochter im ohr papa
wie radikal muss man eigentlich sein
wenn man was verändern will muss man
dann eigentlich radikaler sein als man
eigentlich sein will muss man eine sehr
und ich habe als ich diese wohlstands
verwahrlosten leute da gesehen habe hab
ich das im kopf gehabt die haben sich
für einen weg entschieden auch was
aufmerksam zu machen und haben dabei
übersehen dass wenn man wirklich etwas
verändern will braucht man am ende am
mehrheiten hinter sich genau und nicht
gegen sie und sie haben einen weg
gewählt ausgerechnet um alle gegen sich
aufzubringen
und damit es geschafft dass man das
weswegen sie möglicherweise vielleicht
sogar mit einer guten absicht sich auf
die straße kleben gar nicht mehr
wahrnimmt das ist voll weil andere
jürgen hat ja auch dem ziel des protests
dem ort des protests überhaupt nicht
rechts und logan also wer jetzt und da
wenn es ihnen darum geht dass
lebensmittel nicht verschwendet werden
dann müssen sie zu großen
lebensmittelketten zur zentrale oder
großen märkten und dollar die mülltonnen
gucken und dort mal hier noch s-bahn
salate und sonstwas rausziehen und
zeigen gucken ob es macht mir mut und
dann müssen sie reingehen und den
flieger aber hat im berufsverkehr
stoppen das ist unmöglich dastehen ich
meine die gerne und die wären hätten und
geradezu gezwungen ihr pausenbrot auf zu
essen während sie da sitzen und
verschwenden nichts ja sie haben auch
mit dem problem irgendwann aber damit
gewinnt man keine mehrheiten wenn man
wirklich ein gutes anliegen hat was ist
ja sein kann dann ist das der falsche
weg da bringt man die leute gegen sie
und ich glaube die mehrheit in
deutschland findet diese leute ist
einfach nur peinlich und völlig daneben
und sie werden keinen potter mit
gewinnen sie sagen ihnen gelungen die
medien zug wer überhaupt da stehen aber
erst
nächstes thema
hat muss sich leute auf der straße fest
und stirn den kann sich den tisch muss
sechs leute muss man nicht über andere
natürliche wir sind total verständlich
muss man darüber berichten wollen wir
sahen dass abweichende verhalten da der
rbw tut das gerne das stehen sechs leute
der linkspartei auf irgend einer brücke
und sagen hier man die s bahn schienen
müssen anders gelegt wird versagten aber
bleiben die kamera team dann 230 ich mir
eben die meinung erfahren der dritten
journalist sind hier und sollte meiner
uhr berichten ja oder nein frau riekel
also wir journalisten berichten ja wo
alles was irgendwie aufsehen erregt und
was das leben spannend macht also ich
finde schon dass man darüber berichten
muss und irgendwo wenn ich jetzt in
einem zuhörer denke ich mich ab respect
for diesem 67 typen die sich auch
festplatten mehr und hier reden wir
reden schon ganz lange im jahr wir sind
auf ihre tochter hat gesagt genau wie
radikal muss ich eigentlich sein um
etwas zu bewegen ich weiß nicht das ist
vielleicht es ist tatsächlich eine sache
wir medien könnten natürlich dass jetzt
benutzen und positiv darüber berichten
was sie eigentlich wollen nämlich zum
beispiel lebensmittelverschwendung die
ja tatsächlich ein großes problem in
deutschland ist also irgendwo finde ich
haben haben gehen sollen schon diese
radikale also außerhalb von den
lebensmitteln wollen sie auch hin zu
einer agrarwirtschaft ja gut und die
management 4 auf dem team haben halt
ihre träume abgelesen wird dem fahrer
[Gelächter]
hat da wirklich dass freunde
verlangte er rübenschnitzel gut ich habe
es immer so gut beschäftigt dann hat er
wenigstens sozusagen ist entspannt wäre
sagt glaubt haut die nicht um aber wie
radikal muss man denn sein um etwas zu
verändern ja ich glaube so radikalen
muss man sein denn wir reden ja darüber
und die sanften proteste also in münchen
gibt es jeden samstag einen
autokorso gegen den gegen den impfzwang
und damit hunderte von autos das heißt
die prinzregentenstraße und
maximilianstraße ist alles gesperrt in
der surf und da muss man dann auch lange
warten und das und ich finde münchner
schauen freundlich zu sagen recht hat er
und gut so und jetzt macht mal ein
bisschen schneller
es ist aber nicht wirklich radikal mit
dem bus fahren
[Gelächter]
es ist vielleicht dagegen impfen reicht
ich
bin sogar an den autohäusern oder inhalt
wieder papst noch nicht noch nicht ja
aber man könnte natürlich den
trachtenumzug zum oktoberfest im könnte
man natürlich umfunktionieren denn so
ein protest
umzug yamamoto hoffen bei stepstone at
übertragen dabei hoffen dass sie ja das
ist nicht einfach bei ist auch nein denn
wir haben nie gras landtagswahlen er hat
andere filme gewesen
außerdem bis dahin ist microsoft der
auffassung dass man selbstverständlich
großveranstaltungen stattfinden lassen
also ich nicht etwas weil ihr alle der
meinung man muss man berichten über fünf
leute also
was wichtig und was nicht
wir hatten damit uli hoeneß nicht
darüber müssen wir jetzt direkt weiter
zu dem thema von marc friedrich genau
und zwar mein thema ist die inflation
wir alle werden enteignet durch die
inflation diese war zuletzt fast 5% und
wir spüren es jeden tag eigentlich beim
einkaufen beim heizen beim tanken aber
auch die stromrechnung sehen und dabei
sagte die ezb noch vor wenigen monaten
das es nur temporär wäre und wir sehen
es ist nicht temporär ganz im gegenteil
die inflation ist da und wird auch
bleiben das müsste die ezb auch
kleinlaut zugeben und man zieht auch
dass die inflation auch sicher
beschleunigt für 2022 mit vier prozent
anvisiert vier prozent inflation
bedeutet aber dass wir vier prozent
kaufkraft pro jahr verlieren das
bedeutet überhaupt in der zeit von 18
jahren bei vier prozent würde man die
hälfte seiner kaufkraft verlieren würde
dahinschmolz also fakt ist die ezb
politik hat versagt treibt die schere
zwischen arm und reich immer weiter
auseinander sorgt für sozialen
sprengstoff wird die altersarmut weiter
befeuern wir sehen nicht nur ein
versagen der notenbankpolitik sondern
auch der politik durch eine falsche
energie wende die wir gesehen haben und
dahingehend müssen wir einschreiten und
dahingehend muss jeder auch populär sein
geld in sicherheit bringt vor der
inflation vor dem kaufkraft stunden das
ist mein stichwort ja weil ich habe ihr
buch also so steg gelesen ganz schnell
noch einmal durchgeblättert und ich bin
total deprimiert ihr buch hat mich so
traurig gemacht denn ich habe
[Gelächter]
der bank kann überhaupt nicht trauen wir
haben schließlich brachten auch nicht
dann habe ich immer gedacht also betonen
wollen ich war immer für häuser kaufen
ja gottes willen das mittel dann
besteuert schwer besteuert weil irgendwo
müssen die anbieter das geld her holen
von mir wahrscheinlich ich
überhaupt nicht ich muss heimlich gold
kaufen habe ich nämlich das zeug legen
heimliche gold caro für jene jeden tag
unter 2000 euro
kaufe ich dann an dieser säule
und aber wo vergab ich das ja
wenn sich das rumspricht ja dann habe
ich viele besucher und vor allem wenn
ich jeden tag da hingehe ich brauche man
muss ja dann oft hingehen wenn man
malen gespartes geld umsetzen will wenn
man ein brot kaufen und der bäckerei
muss man so ein goldbarren mitnehmen vor
allem allmend vereinbarung verstecke ich
das zu hause das hab ich auch darüber
nachgedacht und alles was mir einfällt
feld auf dem die pein und vom
tiefkühlfach bis dahin der wäsche auch
nicht ja keksdose nicht und vor allem
vergesse ich es womöglich ja wo ist das
ist das eine dann entnehme ich ihrem
buch das bitcoins also das sicher sind
bislang habe ich mich damit überhaupt
nicht beschäftigt ja aber sie sagen ja
das ist die einzige möglichkeit
wert zu schaffen dann wo die beine nicht
ran können von einer von vielen also
geld also gold diamanten
[Musik]
kollegen kamen ja gerade nicht mehr
kaufen im markt gestern schon mal weißt
du alle gerne wenn man ein und sie dann
halt aber ich heute noch ein thema kurz
erwähnen ergänzen das ultra spannt es in
historische zeiten aber fakt ist
eigentlich müsste die ezb ja um die
inflation zu stoppen die zinsen erhöhen
kann sie aber nicht weil dann würden die
zombie unternehmen in europa pleitegehen
aber auch die zombie länder weil wir
sehen ja in italien frankreich spanien
portugal griechenland sind de facto alle
pleite das heißt wenn die ezb die zinsen
markant erhöhen würde hätten die an ein
kleines euro wird teurer ja ja die
deutsche die europäischen exporte würden
teurer das würde die realwirtschaft
wieder merkt genau aber es gibt ein
aspekt dabei über den wir uns gar nicht
erhalten haben den letzten jahren das
sind nämlich die lohnforderungen die
jetzt kommen wenn die inflation 45
prozent begonnen weil auch die
gewerkschaften mindestens so viel freude
am ende mindestens so viel haben wollen
was wiederum die inflation mindest man
recht erhält oder sogar an weil die
erste frage die einmal hier ein feldherr
friedrich ist ja selbstverständlich die
ist es jetzt vielleicht auch panikmache
kann es sich nicht vielleicht auch
einfach wieder stabilisieren selbst die
ezb sagt er jetzt wir werden uns auf ein
hohes niveau einpendeln wer also wird es
1 4 prozent bei den für 2022
prognostiziert und man darf nicht
vergessen die wahre inflation ist noch
viel hören wird doch nicht angehen wir
haben in saerbeck rechnen die aber in
der stabilisierung bis 2023 der die
haben sich aber bis jetzt immer
verschätzt doch mal ehrlich na also hat
schon geheißen wir werden kein inflation
sehen pustekuchen inflation ist da und
ist ganz schön saftig und im nächsten
jahren sehe ich auf jeden fall weitere
hohe inflationsraten und 34 prozent dann
werden die löhne vielleicht steigen aber
das befeuert an die ganze insel und
spirale und unterm strich von den die
menschen trotzdem also altersarmut droht
ja auch weil die meisten deutschen haben
ja keinen keinen kann kein besitzer also
wenn das geld auf dem konto liegt haben
wir negative wir haben im negativen wir
haben ein negativzins der bördestraße
schon seit 2010 enteignet und die ezb
wird weiter geld drucken und wenn die
geldmenge steigt steigt auch die
inflations aber noch verraten was tut
man denn gegen die inflation ja wenn die
ezb den banken ja wenn die nebenbei frau
riekel und garten
aber solange die notenbanken weltweit
unlimitiert geld drucken muss man
einfach das gegenteil machen im
limitierte werte investieren also alles
mit dem 3 steigen weil es bedeutet
lediglich dass die kaufkraft von geld
immer weniger dann also immobilien
werden wieder inflation aber was muss
der staat tun um die inflation
einzudämmen ja ich kann ganz klar sagen
der staat wird gar nichts tun weil der
staat ist der profiteur der inflation
weil er kann sich auf kosten der bürger
in schulden weil er negative zinsen
bekommt auf seine stadt langenthal
banken tun auch nix also im ganzen
ausgeliefert system muss erst gegen die
wand fahren und wir brauchen an der
stelle würden sozusagen interessant wenn
politisch und so dass man merkt wie ein
so sollen sich die fußnägel aufruhr denn
natürlich müsste eines
sozialdemokratisch geführte
bundesregierung was dagegen tun und
natürlich ist es unanständig und
widerlich dass sich das anzuhören dass
ausgerechnet eine region die von der
arbeiterpartei habe ich doch richtig
sind warten sie mal okay also dessen der
früheren aber dass geführt wird mit
einem mann wie olaf scholz an der spitze
der viele jahre finanzminister
da müsste doch jetzt sozusagen einen 1
gegen katar lohn zu bekommen alles
andere ist ja wenigstens bigott wenn
nicht sogar unanständig und da muss ich
sagen für mich schon ein klares signal
des kanzlers dass er sich das des themas
annimmt und auch die menschen sozusagen
mit dem mit der mit der gewissheit
ausstattet dass unter seiner in seiner
regierungszeit ist nicht noch quasi
eskaliert also eigentlich meinen wir ich
will jetzt nicht so zu sagen es ist ja
klar dass wenn man mehr geld hat macht
man sich auch sorgen und so weiter aber
die meisten leute haben ja gar keine
goldbestand diese sieben karten würden
genau getrennt und dann hat das schon
die haben das recht dass insbesondere
diese regierung ja wir haben die
eigentlich jede aber insbesondere diese
regierung jetzt antworten genau was
sagen da gibt es ja einen ganz
interessanten effekt in dieser regierung
die neue arbeiterpartei könnte man
manchmal glauben ist die fdp das war sie
niemals also christian lindner hat
finanzminister hat jetzt mehrfach gesagt
wir werden er wird was tun gegen die
steigenden energiepreise er wirkt die
pendlerpauschale erhöhen wird darüber
nachdenken wir auf andere weise den
armen leuten geholfen werden das sind ja
völlig neue töne aus der fdp hat sie
früher nie gesagt wird auch nicht gelobt
dafür weil viele trauen dem frieden
nicht aber es ist so
naja
ist der 1 so geht er zum thema machen es
war aber ist das die lösung ist das
grundübel nicht löst eigentlich müssten
tatsächlich die sozialisten und die spd
jeden tag vor der ezb demonstrieren weil
es genau denen ihren
kerngeschäften auch nach europa kommt ja
ich weiss flache aber aber fakt ist
tatsächlich nein die machen gar nichts
und wir müssten eigentlich das
geldsystem komplett neue reformieren
dann gibt es natürlich entwicklungen wie
zum beispiel bitcoin aber fakt ist wir
verlieren unseren wohlstand denkt
deutschland ist in gefahr und das ist
sozialer sprengstoff weil wir die show
aber jetzt
haben wird doch
wir können uns jetzt erklären und
beschreiben das alles
können sie sich vorstellen im radio
ein kleines sparte hat jetzt
aber fakt ist ja jeder wird jetzt
momentan enteigneten meine
lebensversicherung hat geld auf dem
konto oder ob man einfach nur ein
bisschen geld unterm kopfkissen hat der
deutsche muss was machen und da kommt
ein riesen problem auf uns zu was mir
große sorge macht wald sozialer
sprengstoff ist weiß die vor allem die
ärmsten trifft diejenigen die jetzt
gerade jetzt schon kämpfen müssen jetzt
heitz rechnung zahlen der steigt der
gaspreis ums dreifache und wie sollen
diese adäquat fürs alter vorsorgen
altersarmut wird ein riesen thema werden
und die politik ist nicht nur
feuerwehrmann auf der anderen seite
sondern sie sind auch der
brandbeschleuniger war ich kann jetzt
schon voraussagen dass die spd dann wenn
die die jetzt sozusagen der situation
sind alt sind wird die spd hoffentlich
nicht mehr regieren und dann ist sie
wieder da dann wird sie sagen das war
eine schädliche politiker herbert und
dann muss man sich daran erinnert du
musst dann schreiben klar aber es war
genau was mich beunruhigt sie
prophezeien ja einen crash sie sagen das
ist das einzige was man als einzige
zukunftsperspektive dass alles
zusammenbricht und dann wird eine neue
gesellschaft der mensch ländern immer
durch seite oder also das ist ja auch
ereignet bekommen was bedeutet dieser
crash ja wahrscheinlich ein neues
geldsystem endlich bereits zu umarmen
wir sehen doch seit zehn jahren zu einem
dauer krisen modus die notenbanken
drucken weltweit geld zu viel wie noch
nie die schulden steigen euro da es aber
dadurch die inflation nicht gestiegen
bisher die steigt jetzt und zwar wegen
anderer effekt auch wegen der politik
legen nun erwägen den usern und ich ahne
schon irgendwann werden sie
präsidentschaftskandidat einer partei
weil alle die in crash vorausgesagt
haben haben später so karriere gemacht
werden muss ich gar nicht der stein
natürlich jetzt beispielsweise die
barriere von von herr otte ist ja gerade
er so ein bisschen der bearbeitung von
heute ein höhepunkt jetzt sache aber
aber bald überschritten aber fragt uns
doch also im bestehenden system gibt es
ja anscheinend keine lösung war seit
2016 trug die ezb nur geld sie hat den
zins auf dem historischen tief und
enteignet damit eigentlich ganz europa
die ganze bevölkerung ich weiß nicht
warum das immer fragen danach wer jetzt
zwei möglichkeiten haben sagen wir mal
wir haben die mag oder bitcoin was wenn
dann besser welches system meiner
ansicht nach auf jeden fall ein
limitiertes gut was limitiertes durch
einen mathematischen code und das ist
eben nicht geld was einfach auf
knopfdruck produziert wenn du wirst du
nicht für die ezb wirklich produziert
die bilanz hat gerade 8,6 millionen euro
eher auf der hohen kante und ist
ungefähr 100 8 82 prozent vom
europäischen bip also ich würde in
limitierten wert der auf mathematik
beruhen bitcoin ist nicht stabil denn
dort auf seine bahn ist und plötzlich
herunter und dann ist vieles weg dass
das gespann müssen aber auf meine
sendung macht mit freunden also er ist
volatil ist gebe ich zu aber auch nach
oben müssen jetzt über 40.000 dollar und
hat angefangen bei wenigen cent aber es
ist ja nur ein teil der betrachtung
nächste geldsystem wird meiner ansicht
nach digitalen es wird ein digitalen
euro wahrscheinlich geben aber wir
müssen uns klar wir müssen endlich mal
über ein geldsystem sprechen was
nachhaltig ist was den menschen dient
und ist nur einen wenigen weil
profitiert in den krisen haben immer die
reichen immer noch alte systeme gibt es
überhaupt diese alle nur von
beschränkter dauer
mittlerweile genauso wie wir wissen wir
müssen
wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwas also und
ich hab mir vorschlagen es sind die
steigenden benzinpreise wurscht ich
danke sowieso immer nur für 30 euro
auch eine lösung und so an die politik
dass
aber das ist ja mein thema
das ist mein thema ist das ein fehler
begangen und
benzinpreise steigen
oranien vor allem der staat verdient ja
dafür dient ja daran dass ich immer dass
ich immer teurer tanken muss und das
trifft natürlich vor allem auch die
geringverdiener ich denke zum beispiel
im sommer also coroner lässt vielleicht
nach jetzt möchte die normale deutsche
familie in den urlaub fahren das kann
sie sich ja kaum mehr leisten wenn sie
nicht gerade sehr wenn sie nicht
doppelverdiener sind oder dreifach
verdiener die normale familie kann sich
das nicht mehr leisten weil sich der
benzinpreis glaube ich fast verdoppelt
hat ganz abgesehen davon macht mir auch
sorgen die heizkosten denn die die
nebenkostenabrechnungen kommt meistens
im sommer also will holzhaus urlaub
haben dafür doppel gala von dreifach
strompreise das kommt alles in der
nebenkostenabrechnung wie die meisten
menschen so irgendwie mai/juni wenn sie
eigentlich nur urlaub fahren wollen und
wie sollen sich dass die deutschen
leisten können vor allem die senioren
die allein erziehenden studenten
kinderreiche familien oder bis zum teil
zwischen 500 und 600 euro nachzahlen das
haut in die familienkasse doch
wahnsinnig hinein vor allem also ich
meine die senioren mit der kleinen
geringen rente können sich noch
überhaupt nicht leisten und da denke ich
da jetzt alle parteien reden jetzt
darüber dass man irgendwie helfen was
unterstützen was auch hinter zum
beispiel vor der
kreuzung entlastung steuerentlastung
auch vor allem ist benzin muss natürlich
runter dann muss der staat einfach was
verzichten man weiß ja dass 64
cent glaub ich steuern
nimmt der staat von dem von dem benzin
wir haben die tollsten benzinkosten
glaube ich fast weltweit irgendwie wir
haben die wir haben auf jeden fall die
höchsten strompreise weltweit und dann
muss ich auch sagen ist ein bisschen der
heuchelei was die politik dann macht man
auch david machen sie sind macht den
bock zum gärtner weil auf der einen
seite haben sie den völlig chaotische
energiewende vollzogen haben atomenergie
abgestellt und jetzt sagen es irgendwie
hier wir müssen wir müssen jetzt ein
heizkostenzuschuss 175 euro für
diejenigen gibt mehr geld genommen dass
auch noch ein paket von 710 millionen
euro zahlen das heißt wir zahlen den
ihre fehler sie machen einen
historischen fehler nach dem anderen
wird noch lächeln haben sie dafür haben
sie auch mehr steuereinnahmen außer
energie aber der große und bleibende
widerspruch dieser regierung ist dass
sie hat das auch will sie will ja
energie verteuern damit weniger
verbraucht wird das ja die absicht aber
gerne doch das ist aber so du ja auch so
bleiben auf der anderen seite müssen sie
aber denen die sich das nicht leisten
können einen ausgleich geben dass es
gibt immer ein hin und her dann wird das
fängt jetzt gerade erst an da wird es
immer rat der usa black hat ja gesagt
dass wenn man den preis senkt dann
würden vor allem die reichen davon
profitieren das ist ja ganz schön schön
wenn man wenn man die die die
mineralölsteuer gesenkt kriegen alle was
also auch die irgendwie es gar nicht
braucht man muss also dann schon sozial
ausgewählt auf die gruppen zugehen
design benzin ist nicht schwierig solch
an der tankstelle sagen so ist mein
vermögenssituation des jag
kilometerpauschale sondern eher im weg
also die herren
es ist die stunde in der der staat
darüber nachdenken muss das wäre so
langsam in dem anderen lassen muss und
handeln und zwar jetzt dass leute geld
zurückkriegt so also wir können ja
natürlich kroner maßnahmen mit 350
milliarden euro
finanzieren und kann mal eben ganz
schnell 200 milliarden freigeschaltet
noch scholz als finanzminister bei
crawler toll da war ich stolz dass das
möglich ist dass wir das konnten dass
wir da nicht pleitegehen keine lampen
mehr angehen züge weiterfahren also dass
man am nächsten tag nachdem man zwei
milliarden euro frei geschaltet hat noch
im gleichen wohlstandsland leben kann
wenn das aber war es dann müssen jetzt
auch große summen bereitgestellt werden
um den menschen diese höheren kosten
auszugleichen wer soll es denn sonst
machen und ich darf noch mal ganz kurz
dann in steuergeld hat den leuten ja
sowieso schon mal gehört also es ist ja
nicht so vorübergehen aber steuergeld
ich muss mich auch selber immer noch mal
daran erinnern weil politiker ganz so
tun als wäre es ihr eigenes geld man ja
dann jetzt umgehen das ist aber unser
geld und wer könnte ja auch auf den
gedanken kommen zu sagen wir haben
steuern hohe steuern bezahlt und das war
so eine art
sicherungsanlage für notzeiten nämlich
jetzt wo alles teurer wird und jetzt
möchte ich ein stück des geldes zurück
und das wird die in die lichtung laufen
über hier in zuschuss da an zuschuss
bloß nicht nur fehler bekämpfen und zu
geben dass die energiewende für simple
tor das man natürlich strom und
gas nicht endlos teurer machen kann um
die leute zum sparen zu bringen und zum
zum umdenken zu bringen diese erpressung
genaugenommen dieser preis aber trotzdem
aber trotzdem ist es doch eine farce
dass die politik sich jetzt darstellen
sagt wissen die große retter mehrere
schützen jetzt die steuertöpfen über den
leuten aus denn das geld haben aber
eigentlich haben sie diese
grundproblematik selbst initiiert und
implementiert naja durch eine falsche
energiepolitik hat durch
diese politik politik darf man nicht
sagen finde ich das ist mir zu
allgemeinen sondern auch bei dieser
regierung genau hingucken erkennt man
doch jetzt bruchlinien und es ist ja
nicht die aufgabe des finanzministers
ausgaben vorzuschlagen ganz im gegenteil
tut er aber lindner sagt dann müssen wir
was für die für die autofahrer tun und
hier und da was tun um die energiekosten
auszugleichen es wäre eigentlich aufgabe
entweder des arbeits und sozialministers
oder noch mehr des wirtschaftsministers
aber habeck habe ich den eindruck 70 gar
nicht als wirtschaftsminister sieht sich
als klimaminister das was da passiert
ist seine grob gesprochen seine absicht
energie muss teurer werden damit weniger
vor braucht wird und dass da leute
darunter leiden ist nicht sein erstes
anliegen und der kanzler schläft der
könnte natürlich auch längst mal
aufgetaucht sein und dazu ein wort
gesagt haben tut er aber nicht das heißt
dass sport vor sich hin und die größte
überraschung ist muss ich noch mal sagen
lindner und fdp da waren die früher nie
unter aufpolieren ist ein großer
aber traurige kommen nochmals der
kernthese die fand ich nämlich so
wichtig niemand sollte in deutschland
frieren und das ist ja eigentlich auch
schon so ein grund punkt gegen neben dem
benzin dass er wirklich schon familien
auch darüber nachdenken wann sie jetzt
heizen wie lange sie die heizung laufen
lassen weil es so teuer wird was kann
man dagegen tun ja man kann zum beispiel
wir reden ja von menschen mit geringen
einkommen ja also man kann zum beispiel
das wohngeld erhöhen und dort mit einen
heizkostenzuschuss zum beispiel weg
frankreich frankreich hat auch einen
heizkostenzuschuss einen einmaligen an
seine bürger verschickt die also wenig
verdienen und man muss das auch mal
menschlich sehen ja also der
durchschnittsrentner
hat so eine rente zwischen 13 und 14 100
euro
13 14 100 euro es gibt auch im neuen
teil ja ja da muss aber davon miete
zahlen darf muss man vielleicht sein
handy zahlen damit muss er sich auch was
zu essen kaufen können und was
vielleicht zum arzt mit den öffentlich
verkehrsmittel fahren können und man
macht sich das kaum bewusst da wie knapp
das geld für millionen menschen in
deutschland ist der wir die wir besitzen
wir werden erhöhte benzinpreise und und
heizkosten wahrscheinlich irgendwie
wegstecken können sagen ja okay das
vielleicht hört es auch mal irgendwann
auf aber mein gedanke geht an die
menschen die wirklich ganz wenig haben
wir machen uns ja euro sind schon viele
ganz viel geld wie entscheiden darüber
ob ich mir ob ich mir eine wurstsemmel
kaufe oder ob ich mir vielleicht eine
zeitung kaufen müssen ja die müssen ja
es gibt ja so viele kleine kosten die
damit gemachten vor allem brauche ich
auch was zum sparen wenn irgendetwas
passiert und das gilt auch für
kinderreiche familien und es gilt für
alleinerziehende und es gilt auch für
studenten
die haben dann ein kleines bafög oder
eine kleine unterstützung von ihren
eltern
nicht suchen die die heizkosten
nachzahlungen stärken also das ist
wirklich das finde ich wirklich
schwierig und ich verfolge das alle
parteien nach lösungen suchen und alle
reden darüber herlind ganz besonders ich
finde aber das muss jetzt geschehen und
nicht nur darüber reden und dann
diskutieren und vielleicht und wie auch
immer sonne es muss jetzt etwas
geschehen damit die leute auch ein
bisschen optimismus haben nach dieser
schweren corona ja netz muss ich einmal
das wort corona auch mal sagen wir eine
brauchen die leute hoffnung und eine
aussicht auch mal dass es besser wird
und ich finde wir sind dann wirklich
noch eine solidargemeinschaft und auch
da muss man sagen kanzler auf waren ja
also muss es mal langsam an nämlich was
ich sage das ganz schlimm dass er leute
werden sich auf unterstützen ich würde
ich wäre sogar für ein heizungs so lief
menschen die das brauchen ja auch
persönlich für menschen die wir es
brauchen ja da hast du den zahlen liegt
dabei oberhalb
denkt nach das hilft den richtigen aber
es schützt die falschen sozusagen wenn
man das jetzt täten also quasi es bei
mir bei dir wie man bei 980 würdigungen
von kriegen ja ich habe von 980
zwischenrufen rechnung seit 1960
zwischenrufen das nur mal 2000 euro
ausgebrochen
2000 euro von nominal nie im leben zu
wenig war nur
das war nun ist aber was ich meine ist
wir müssen aufpassen dass er nicht durch
persönliches quasi soziales engagement
diejenigen aus der pflicht nimmt die in
der pflicht werden nämlich politiker die
über die ausgaben verfügen und jetzt sag
ich's halt dann mal muss christian
lindner das jetzt ja und muss dann zum
robert habeck sagen das machen wir jetzt
so wenn er so weiter macht dass er
irgendwann auch bundeskanzler der
lindenallee ja dann aber für welche
partei ist jetzt das wort das es ihm
vielleicht auch ein
[Gelächter]
tolles anliegen und es ist ein
großartige idee von ihm zu sagen und
auch mutig wir müssen denen helfen die
jetzt unsere hilfe brauchen aber da
müssen ja auch taten folgen also ich
mich auch sagen mir kommen mittlerweile
er sofort wenn die politik auch ein
bisschen abgehoben vor allem auch wenn
wir auf die grünen schauen die ja auch
mit regieren deswegen meine frage an sie
herr friedrich wie es ist denn jetzt
eigentlich man muss ja sagen es ist ja
schon eine gewisse klientel politik auch
also vor allem wenn man sich die grünen
an schaumberg anschaut der lieber
klimaminister ist als
wirtschaftsminister ist das vielleicht
das problem der ganzen sache warum sich
dem nicht mit schwung und werf
angenommen wird dass die politik einfach
schon anderen sphären schwebt über
absolute sind haben eine gewisse hybris
ja machen den politik versuchen
natürlich ihre wählergruppe zu
befriedigen aber gesagt gesamtheitliche
lösungen werden nicht gefunden also
nimmt er macht politik damit er wieder
gewählt und weil das natürlich angst
haben weil sie die impfpflicht doch
befürwortet haben dass sie bei der
nächsten bundestagswahl rausgekegelt
werden und jeder guckt also wird er
gewählt wird soll ich glaube nicht dass
sie eine hybris habe ich glaube man
schon die stecken den anfängen ich habe
er den einen und das ist eine stimme
regierung wir haben da bin ich bei ihr
haben ja miterlebt wie die genesenen
spannend auf ein anderes glaube ich nach
wie vor dass lauterbach dahinter steckt
und nicht herr wieder hat er wieder im
auftrag von lauterbach gemacht aber das
nicht mein problem sondern die enduro r
stoppt man schon gewaltig aktivismus ich
schon begründen wenn also ein feuer aber
was hinterher passiert ist das habeck
der klimaminister nämlich die gesamte
bauindustrie schockiert hat indem er die
subventionen für ökologisches bauen von
einfachen anderen gestoppt hat da waren
häuslebauer standen fassungslos davor
baufirmen und architekten die ganze
branche der hat gar nicht begriffen was
er da tut also das sind die ersten
anfänge dieser koalition übrigens hat
rot grün mit gerd schulter auch mal so
angefangen muss ich sagen doch doch das
mache er nicht gerüttelt da hat nichts
funktioniert das sind anfänger einer
koalition das einzige was bisher kommen
wieder drauf was bisher rund läuft es
sehr fdp muss ich sagen es
[Gelächter]
ist ja irgendwie stelle für die fdp von
hans ulrich wolter druck
aber jetzt haben wir ganz kurz
unterbrechen und dann geht es weiter mit
gerhard schröder und was claus strunz
eigentlich über den altkanzler sagt
wir sind zurück und wir wollen keine
zeit verlieren bei deutschlands dauer
meinen sendungen und legen direkt los
mit spox ja also ich hab mich heute den
ganzen tag eigentlich wollte ich gar
nicht ob ich mich aufgeregt über gerhard
schröder gerhard schröder sie erinnern
sich das war mal unser bundeskanzler und
ich fand den damals ganz gut achtung
zeit für ein geständnis ich habe den
mann sogar mal gewählt und vielleicht
bin ich deshalb so wütend was jetzt aus
ingo anders und was er anstellt mit
wladimir putin und mit seiner
lobbytätigkeit weil gazprom da ist er
jetzt im aufsichtsrat
und das finde ich in der sache
vielleicht noch hinnehmbar
aber in den finanzen unanständig denn
der trainer würde alimentiert von
unserem geld von meinem geld von ihrem
geld von dem geld aus unserer runde mit
steuergeldern bekommt er ganz ähnliche
privilegien bezahlt das ist auch ganz
okay im büro in den museen den
natürlichen fahrer mitarbeiter man sagt
so ungefähr eine viertel million im jahr
kostet das alles zusammen jetzt nimmt
aber eine million euro sagt man als
gehalt im aufsichtsrat von gazprom also
indirekt von wladimir putin das bedeutet
wir deutschen zahlen einen finanzieren
einen lobbyisten der gegen deutschland
arbeitet und von dort lässt er sich auch
noch geld gibt und das finde ich
wirklich nicht nur für den
sozialdemokraten sondern für einen
anständigen menschen schwierig und mein
vorschlag würde lauten ich will jetzt
gar nicht weiter auf die palme sondern
ich komme schon wieder runter gekrabbelt
und sage herr schröder sie haben hartz 4
5 sie haben hat es hier eingeführt jeder
hartz 4 empfänger wer also zu seinen
staatlichen geld was dazuverdient da
wird es angerechnet und verrechnet und
das fordere ich auch von ihnen geben sie
uns unser geld zurück solange sie eine
million von putin kriegen zahlen sie die
viertelmillion im jahr zurück solange
diese eine million fließt ich finde das
sind sie deutschland schuldig also darf
ich darauf antworten klar da habe ich
eine gespaltene antwort der erste teil
ist also im deutschen rechtssystem gibt
es das prinzip der rache nicht also man
kommt damit nicht durch wenn er seine
ansprüche hat auch pension kriegt er die
kann man aber gesetzlich verändern was
ich aber sagen wollte ist dass er gegen
deutschland arbeitet kann man nicht
sagen deutschland bezieht mehr als die
hälfte seines gasverbrauchs auch
russland deutschland bezieht oder
generiert fast die hälfte seines benzins
aus russischem öl da sitzt ja nicht nur
schröder sitzt nicht nur bei gazprom
sondern auch bei rosneft dass der
ölkonzern im verwaltungsrat neben bp
übrigens also wenn wir das gebrauchen
und verbrauchen und kein wort darüber
verlieren dass da beschwert sich ja
keiner das ist zu viel ich wir wollen
jetzt umsteigen in den quellen usw dann
kann es nicht falsch sein dass in
deutschland in aufsichtsgremien der
lieferanten sitzt und wenn wir den
bundeskanzler jetzt treten weil er nicht
in moskau war der muss unbedingt mit
putin sprechen kann man auch nicht den
früheren kanzler dafür bestrafen dass
ein draht zu putin hat erster teil der
antwort zwei parteien richtig ist aber
wenn einer einen riesen ankunft hat
müssen natürlich pensionen und anderes
gegengerechnet werden und zwar nicht nur
bei schröder sondern generell um das
müsste man mal gesetzlich verhindern
also ich will was zudem erstens in dem
ländlichen ersten teil seiner nachdem
der gast nachdem ich in der ersten
hälfte des handelns gedacht habe du bist
ein fanboy von christian linder weil ich
jetzt es war ein irrtum bewusst
eigentlich ein fan
das hätte mir früher auffallen können
aber okay dass das vorweg ich finde dass
man natürlich das argumentieren kann
dass jemand wenn wir dort rohstoffe
beziehen
darauf aufpasst und unsere und unsere
interessen vertritt mein eindruck ist
aber nicht dass unsere interessen
vertreten werden sondern mein eindruck
ist dass bei einem druckmittel von putin
nämlich ich bin euer lieferant bei am
gegner im ukraine konflikt ausgerechnet
mein ich sag jetzt mal wirklich
persönlich ehemaliger bundeskanzler dem
gegner auf dem schoß sitzt und diese
symbolik die finde ich wirklich
problematisch und ich hielt mich darüber
auf weil alle haben bei gerhard schröder
ja schon als er im amt war immer gesagt
naja gut also der ist halt ein schlingel
der isla wiener und der verdient auch
gern geld und wartet mal ab wenn er
danach und ich habe immer gesagt nee dem
geht's am ende schon um den
sozialdemokratischen gedanken dem geht
es am ende schon um die leute in
deutschland und jetzt muss ich
feststellen verdammt noch mal kaum ist
er nicht mehr kann sagt geht es ihm doch
nur uns sein bankkonto und ich würde
jetzt dieses gegenrechnen ich finde das
können wir als initiative von heute auf
ihr es war aber etwas anderes sagen ich
weiß dass es wahrscheinlich eine
übermenschliche anforderung ist und
jeder muss bevor sie aufstellt mal eben
sich selber einreichen gerhard schröder
könnte sozusagen diesen ganze kritik
nicht nur abfedern sondern ganz
gegenteil wenden wenn er erklären würde
ich habe jetzt hier einnahmen über die
spekulieren alle und es ist eigentlich
sogar für
ja und deshalb so lange das so ist
verzichte ich auf die zahlungen
oder richtig ja also sozusagen das ist
wie ich finde menschen die viel
verdienen könnten auch auf kindergeld
verzichten ja also es ist sozusagen eine
art eine art wie anstand oder oder
gefühl für harfe solo haben also immer
über solidargemeinschaften zu quatschen
und wenn es darum geht sich der
solidargemeinschaft nach oben zu enden
zu entziehen das regt mich dann auch ich
finde ist diese ganze herrlichkeit von
schröder dieses ganze was ich hab's ja
gerade schon versucht schlecht er sprach
mich total an ihm habe ich vertrauen er
hat auch bisweilen gute politik also und
jetzt macht er da so kommt auch unter
stress könnte ich
habe
da könnte ja sagen von den von meiner
pension bezahle ich die heizkosten in
diesem jahr von 1000 berlinern und wenn
doch schon mal was
immer an einer sache widersprechen das
ist nicht ein einseitiges druck
verhältnis russlands uns gegenüber die
russen sind auf ihrer gamespot
existenziell angewiesen eigentlich noch
mehr als wir auf die importe denn ich
glaube drei viertel des staatshaushalts
bestehen die haben ja sonst
wirtschaftlich nichts zustande gebracht
während der regierungszeit von putin sie
können nur rohstoffe exportieren wenn
sie das nicht mehr können haben sie ein
riesenproblem also insofern können die
uns auch nicht einfach abschnüren dass
da tun sie sich selbst mit schadenfrohen
geben ich verstehe schon dass da jetzt
wieder auf die sachebene kommen willst
weil er
ja
doch schon zu erweitern jetzt noch mal
um den ganzen zensieren doch herr
schröder auch oft erlebt sie auch in die
bunte damals eingeführt dass auch
politiker porträtiert wäre ja auch wenn
sie berichtet wird herr schröder hatten
sich 1 1 getrennt
ich meine als störend graf in dem
boulevard baden hat sozusagen ein
geschenk konnte man sie überhaupt nicht
vorstellen in der redaktion kursiert der
schöne spruch der hat ein henkel an kopf
her und bdv kann ihn davon tragen wenn
sie nur
ein bisschen böse und meint der
amerikanische also eine amerikanische
addierte gehabt jahren mit mitte frau
und seiner seite und erstmal damit seine
ein erster richtiger großer auftritt war
mit helau pottschalk und da wurde
darüber gesprochen was passiert wenn er
nicht treu ist und ich glaube ich eher
auf trennt die hütte
ich meine ja politiker hat es jemals
zuvor gesagt wobei man ja über viele
politiker und ihr privatleben was sagen
könnte wieder nicht serielle montag ich
glaube diese begriffliche
hinter nike ist es gibt keine
schnittmengen gleich also habe ich das
immer verstand so darüber möchte ich
jetzt nicht reden aber
die haben wissen sie sich weitgehend mal
erweitert wenn das anders gemacht hätte
er damit seinem leben gespielt also
höchstens in der allerletzten
schlussphase einer ehe dann muss es
neues angefangen haben war es so aber
das war dann schnell das
auto legal rhein mit seinen anzügen
seine zigarre regionen einen festen ja
ich meine ich habe manchmal erlebt wenn
er dann gerne
laufe des abends wenn es ein bisschen
länger dauert die capri fischer singt
und solche sachen ja beim ersten in yann
l rotwein getrunken sich im kanzlerbüro
es da noch für die menschen die mit dem
begriff nichts anfangen so ungefähr 120
euro die flasche
kann man ganz schön viel heizen dafür
ein charmanter typ sehr männlich und der
öffentlichkeit zugewandt ja und lässt
auch gerne ein bisschen hineingucken und
ich meine sein privatleben ist wirklich
aufregend das muss man schon sagen ja
und so gesehen eine frau hat am scharfen
schwert gehöre ja ich kann gesagt auch
wenn man ist vielleicht teuer ist gleich
ohne putins polen
schröder hatte ich mein politiker ja war
die auflage immer okay ich meine das
kann man von anderen politikern
[Gelächter]
herbrich bei olaf scholz privat
gab ihm vor kurzem auch ein bericht über
olaf scholz und seine frau aber auf den
titel hat es nicht
olaf scholz geht am sonntag mit brötchen
und dann ein halbes vollkornbrot da sind
auf das ist noch mal eine halbe so mehr
verdienen tragen wie denn dazu also
sollte jetzt herr schröder verzichten
unser altkanzler oder wowereit absolut
ich bin absolut mit den beiden herren
d'accord es ist ja so dass politiker
natürlich die goldene drehtür nützen
nach ihren politischen karriere und sich
das vergolden lassen dann finde ich
super okay ja ich bin ein bisschen
traurig muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen wenn
herr gabriel der deutschen bank im
aufsichtsrat
habe also es gibt es gibt ist sollten
die karenzzeit geben und es sollte
tatsächlich auch so was wie eine
anrechnung geben dass man sagt okay der
schauwerkstatt war bei der zeit ja zum
weiter jetzt besser gefallen ja aber
alles gibt halt einfach eine gewisse
würde die das amt auch in sich trägt und
dann wirtschaftsminister war für die
arbeiterpartei spd geht danach nicht zur
deutschen bank das hat doch wirklich
kein stil muss ich sie und dahingehend
putin oder also ich finde die idee dass
man strategisch sagt liefern uns mit mit
öl und gas was wir auch wirklich
brauchen vor allem in zeiten wie diesen
wo die gasspeicher leer sind gar nicht
so schlecht und warum ist man sich nicht
mit denen gut stehen stellen also dahin
gehen fällt jetzt nichts verwerflich ist
auch eines tages nochmal den draht zu
putin den persönlichen kann man lässt
genossen mehr weiß dass mit der ukraine
noch alles passieren
der deutschen er hat ihnen immer am
telefon das grab von k s sind die haben
auch seine prominenz wie sie beide und
dahingehend ist es gar nicht schlecht da
auch mal den direkten draht zu haben
tatsächlich ja du bist
mach ich ihn zu fördern damit endgültig
bewiesen dass du am liebsten schröder
wärs ja
in der kombination bisschen schnell
wunderbar wie gegen keinen seien in der
sendung ist tut mir sehr leid und
vielleicht können wir das ja mal
irgendwann einführen klar es muss man
dann darüber entscheiden wir reden aber
jetzt erstmal über die katholischen
kirche ja wir kommen sozusagen zum
messwein mal nicht über corona sondern
über die andere pandemie und die andere
pandemie ist der missbrauch von kindern
in der katholischen kirche das ist der
bleibende größte sündenfall in der
geschichte der kirche und vielleicht
einer der größten in der geschichte der
menschheit unglaublich das aufsichts
befohlene mit religion erziehung
befasste menschen sich an kindern
vergriffen haben im schutzraum kirche
unglaublich jetzt rast die kirche auch
ungebremst auf den abgrund zu also die
amtsgerichte kommen gar nicht mehr
hinterher
termine für den für den kirchenaustritt
anzubieten und es sind gerade noch 12
prozent der deutschen der meinung dass
man großes vertrauen in die katholische
kirche hat kann von den katholiken sind
es übrigens auch nur 29 das ist
verheerend die trauen ihrer eigenen
kirche nichts mehr zu so aber
konsequenzen hat in der kirche niemand
gezogen der erste der jetzt was mal
gesagt hat sich aus der deckung getraut
hat war der münchner kardinal marx der
gesagt hat er könnte sich schon
vorstellen dass manche priester
verheiratet besser aufgehoben wären aber
da kann man ja sicher sein dass
scheitert wieder an rom sowie andere
reformvorschläge auch die sind über
jahrzehnte immer wieder an rom
gescheitert das hat sage ich jetzt mehr
die katholische kirche vor dem untergang
retten will der muss sie neu gründen der
muss eine kirche haben die erstens den
zölibat aufgeht die
dafür sorgt dass priester heiraten
können und zwar auch
gleichgeschlechtlich die dafür sorgt
dass frauen priesterin wären
bischöfinnen und tabs den da darf gar
nichts ausgeschlossen sein die außerdem
geschiedene wiederverheiratete und denen
nicht die sakramente verweigert was sie
bisher tut und die dann noch als letztes
dafür sorgt fünf punkte sind für mich
die als letztes dafür sorgt dass schwule
und lesben in der kirche auch getraut
werden können dann wäre die kirche im 21
jahrhundert angekommen und ich glaube
dass die kirche und der glauben übrigens
der die sakramente die gottesdienst
alles das man was man an riten und
traditionen in der kirche kennt sollten
erhalten bleiben da bin ich überhaupt
sich dagegen das ist eine frage der
katholiken wenn sie das wollen sollen
sie es weitermachen also würde ich ihnen
sagen verändert nur die schale in der
glauben aufbewahrt wird und die schale
muss unbefleckt seien die schale ist für
mich die organisierte kirche und ohne
eine neugründung geht es nicht ist das
naiv ist dass
das
todesmutig so was zu fordern völlig
sinnlos ich glaube es nicht ich glaube
dass grund stürzende veränderung immer
illusionär erschienen sind am anfang
dann hat sich doch viel verändert ich
hoffe sehr darauf dass sich menschen
finden die so was in angriff nehmen das
könnte ja das beispiel schon damit
anfangen dass die kirche sind nämlich
auch ihrem buch zu den reichsten
organisationen weltweit gehört und die
kirche könnte mal etwas von ihrem
reichen hinten und
ich meine das meinen sie was machen sie
jetzt offenbar habe ich heute auch mal
also klasse sie heute als ehemalige spd
wähler auf die offenbare mich jetzt als
christlich gläubiger zahlen übrigens
ohne eigentlich die kirchensteuer nein
evangelisch ich zahle auch aus
überzeugung die kirchensteuer und ich
zahle sie beispiel die kirche
kindergärten fördert ich war auf einem
streng katholischen nasen es wurde auch
von der kirche von malteser gefördert
ich bin aus überzeugung christin und
aber aus überzeugung zahle ich auch die
kirchensteuer dementsprechend meine
frage uli müssten vielleicht alle
katholiken evangelisch werden über
eine 5.1
stand wenn ich am tisch übersicht und
offenbar weniger kritisch zuspitzen wenn
ich natürlich sagen du möchtest dass
quasi alle evangelischen aber in
idyllischen heiraten ja die china sind
nach ihrem ganzen
ja ich habe ausdrücklich gesagt der
glauben der ritus die gottesdienste die
traditionen sollen so bleibt
mexikanische galten sie vor allem
zusammen gehen sondern um die ökumene
mir geht es darum dass die dass der
katholische glaube er hat den glaubens
inhalt der die marienverehrung
beispielsweise findet in der
evangelischen kirche überhaupt nicht das
sollen die alles behalten dann will ich
überhaupt nichts dann verändern sondern
die sollen ihre schande
seitigen die katholiken sollen dafür
sorgen dass diese in schande geratene
kirche gereinigt wird und alles andere
sollen sie behalten die evangelische
kirche ist in ich war mal evangelisch
die ist für mich so verwechselbar und
mit was ist mit allem also ich hab mal
das letzte was sie erlebt hat war eine
taufe in im berliner dom im seitenschiff
da ging es zu wie im kindergarten dabei
ein einziges geschrei da muss ich da bin
ich dann raus
tragen also sage ich doch gar nicht du
kannst ja evangelischen habe ich gar
nichts dagegen aber die ist mir zu
beliebig also wenn ich heute wieder ein
kirche eintreten müsste wird oder wollte
würde ich wohl überlegt ohne diese
schale die ist mir befleckt da nämlich
nichts mehr zu tun haben würde ich was
glauben ritus und so weiter angeht
ernsthaftigkeit der religion muss ich
mal sagen die katholische kirche ist
wenn man sich zu sehr streiten aber wm
definitiv klaus gedanken aber nicht ganz
falsch weil vieles was du geschrieben
das ist ja so eine evangelischen kirche
die evangelische kirche wurde ja auch
gegründet weil die menschen mit der
katholischen kirche nicht mehr der chor
war nicht wegen der sexualmoral
den absteigern interessant das ist doch
inzwischen das wird doch in der in der
katholischen kirche weithin diskutiert
das was ich vorgeschlagen aber alles
wird diskutiert wird gefordert
inzwischen sängers inserent inzwischen
ist der ära final in münchen dafür dass
priester heiraten dürfen es gibt einen
einen dialogprozess ein reformprozess
der sogenannte synodale weg dann eben
auch bischöfe könnte wird alles was ich
eben aufgezählt habe diskutiert weil die
selber sehen wenn sie es nicht tun gehen
sie zu grunde die menschen wenden sich
ab dazu also ich finde das schreit
eigentlich danach dass sich die beiden
kirchen wiedervereinigen
main das seelische kirche mit dem marien
glauben und der heiligenverehrung der
boden also ich meine der glaube ist eine
sehr persönliche angelegenheit und man
kann ja diese marienverehrung ist ja
jedem selbst überlassen
aber das was sie fordern also neuer wein
in alten schläuchen oder oder oder wie
auch immer
sorry da bin ich wenn ich wenn ich wenn
ich sage ich ich hebe das zölibat auf
ich lasse frauen zu kirchenämter und zu
das ist ja tatsächlich das was ende ich
bin katholisch gewesen das ist natürlich
genau das was in der evangelischen
kirche stattfindet aber es wäre doch ein
großartiger gedanke wenn diese beiden
kirchen wieder zusammenfinden würden
und ich meine das
ist alles richtig ja das meine ich
deutschland für deutschland ist es
bestimmt alles richtig aber die
katholische kirche ist ja quasi ein
internationaler deshalb macht es ja auch
nicht angenommen und ehrlich gesagt ist
katholischen kirche deutschland also ich
will nicht sagen egal aber es ist jetzt
nicht ihre vordringlichste platz und das
ist lateinamerika hey die keine
kirchensteuer ja natürlich ich will aber
nicht nur einen punkt ich finde diese
réunion irgendwie ihn faszinieren
gedanken ich wollte man noch was zu den
menschen in der katholischen kirche
sagen gesichter beheimatet fühlen die da
ihr leben zum teil ganz verbracht haben
sowas der absolut überwiegende teil der
menschen in der katholischen kirche fast
keine kleinen kinder an das vergewaltigt
keine liner nannte er absolut über räume
da
sowieso
nicht so dass ich würde mir ich kann es
nicht beweisen ganz am anfang sogar der
überwiegende teil aller priester in der
katholischen kirche fasst ja auch keine
kleine anderen weiß nicht was auch nein
das macht neben einzelfall nicht besser
ich will nur einmal
noch einmal eine kerze an für all
diejenigen die rottaler überzeugung aus
nächstenliebe ja aus wir müssen für die
älteren menschen die heizkosten
übernehmen das könnte auch ein gedanke
einer gemeinde sein und ich bin sicher
da draußen in deutschland gibt es
gemeinden durch solche gedanken gedacht
werden für all diejenigen die durch
diese
unfassbaren missetaten in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden weil
dieses wärmegefühl dass sie empfinden
dadurch geschändet ist
mit bei denen bin ich mit meinen
gedanken auch ja bei dir ähnlich läuft
auch die wende ich doch in der hand
liegt dass ich heute sage ich doch die
muss ja die muss ja eine neue kirche aus
der kirche von solchen gern haften
läuten wir sehen das inzwischen soweit
das ist ein papst beim nur er gestorben
ist ein papst hat offensichtlich gelogen
wann hat man und wer noch nie gelogen
hat obwohl der held die hand weh aber
es ist auch noch kommt ja erst mal ein
bisschen vergessen also wir hatten ja
wir hatten ja auch diese pädophilen
fälle auch in anderen ländern irland
australien usa kanada überall einer und
die katholische kirche ist ja eigentlich
dafür bekannt seit hunderten von jahren
sie hat kriege mitgetragen aber den
nazis mit dabei hat er noch nicht an
ihren noch mehr dabei
wäre ist über
seinen anwalt er dafür wurden kriege
geführt wurden menschen verbrannt und
die hat sich nie wirklich mit ruhm
bekleckert und es ist eine der reichsten
verein unterwelt zu doch mal ganz
ehrlich wenn die auch ein teil wenn sie
wirklich diese nächstenliebe leben würde
dann könnten wir uns geld jetzt
ausschütten an die armen kinder in
afrika an diejenigen die nicht heizen
können ins grab nein die stapel mehr
geld haben noch finanzskandalen mit der
vatikanbank und sobald ich sie vergessen
so ein bisschen die die quote auch die
erdung die man auch empfindet und ich
muss ehrlich sagen dass ich hier auch
was mit tradition zu tun hat und ich
finde wenn man es immer alles so
schlecht macht ich dann ist man
eigentlich gegen jeden der dort auch
erdung nein erlaubt ist es gut jeder
kann sein glauben haben also ich ich
brauche die kirche nicht für glauben ich
kann trotzdem an etwas glauben ich
glaube einfach der die kirchen sind ein
unternehmen das sind unternehmen der
seit tausenden jahren gut läuft der
beste business plan der welt würde ich
jetzt mal sagen ja und sie nutzen ihre
macht aus schamlos aus und deswegen bin
ich kein fan der kirche war seit jeher
immer unrecht instanz obernkirchen ich
glaube dass viele menschen
einen glauben brauchen und ihn suchen
und die frage ist ob er noch geboten
wird ob also derjenige der ihn anbietet
in diesem fall die katholische kirche
glaubwürdig ist und das tun kann was die
kirchensteuer an geht übrigens oder du
tust dann nicht nur vorjahres ist ja so
als würde die kirche aus ihrem verein
gestellt haben wenn sie glauben tun
haben sie einen schönen abend bis morgen
20.15 cis bei
[Musik]